for my ultimate special occasion lunch
I've got some stunning and I mean
stunning lobsters
and I'll be cooking them very simply
with chili and garlic butter serving
them with Bloody Mary linguine
I'm going to start with a pasta sauce
I love the Indulgence in this dish
if I was doing this for the kids I'd
scratch the vodka and just do like a
virgin Mary but a bit of a grown-ups
fish now pan nice and hot special olive
oil
onions in seasoning Touch of salt and
pepper
garlic be nice and generous with your
garlic it's not just your average tomato
sauce it's a royal stunning tomato sauce
and you're in for a big treat
season the onions and garlic the Tabasco
that'll give that really nice lift
little pinch of celery salt
spice that up with Worcester sauce it
instantly colors the tomatoes goes
brilliantly well with the celery salt
Tabasco and that nice caramelized garlic
a little light sprinkling of sugar all
the Worcester sauce has reduced down
we've got this nice sweet spicy sticky
garlicky onion base glaze with a couple
of spoons of vodka in
lovely
chopped tomatoes in
a little touch of water
look at the color of that sauce
check the seasoning
[Music]
bring that up to the ball and cook it
out six to eight minutes reduce it down
slowly turn down the Gas let that simmer
with my sauce simmering I can move on to
a delicious breadcrumb topping to dress
my linguine
fly off my bed cars get them nice and
crispy but don't put too much oil in
there otherwise the bread will just
absorb it they become greasy
beautifully season them
and they go really nice and golden brown
30 seconds before they come out flat
leaf parsley roll that through your
bread crumbs and that is going to finish
the linguine on top
you can hear how crisper they are
before I cook the linguine I'm going to
make the chili butter that will flavor
my Lobster
get your chili and slice it I want to
take advantage of all those seeds
trillion touch your soul
a nice clove of garlic
and here's some parsley
[Music]
start breaking that down but I'm looking
for a lovely garlic chili paste exactly
like that now don't overdo it with the
butter
her Butters are a great way to flavor
fish and meat they can be used as a
stuffing in dishes like chicken kiev or
added towards the end of a Dish as a
delicious glaze
lobsters
they're already cooked so
firmly placed Lobster flat on your board
there's a little crisscross here lying
there and a line going across put the
point of the knife in and just push
through
the head turn the lobster around
cut through the lobster
snap the legs off
snap the claws off just get the back of
your knife
crack them
spread that beautiful butter on go into
the heads as well
and then the claws take off bits of the
shell
and get a little bits of butter in there
this can be done way in advance for me
the longer that chili butter sits on top
of that Lobster the better the flavor
especially when they hit the grill
[Music]
while my Lobster firms up in the fridge
I can finish cooking my linguine water
brought up to the boil
seasoned nicely and a little touch of
olive oil now linguine first that's
going to take the longest eight to ten
minutes in
as linguine starts softening at the
bottom just gently turn that around
always wait the linguine is nice and
soft that way you don't break those nice
strands give that a good mix get your
lid back on
[Music]
and bring that to the ball rapidly
after eight to ten minutes my linguine
should be perfect you want it Al Dente
slightly firm
um not too chewy absolutely spot on
train that into a colander shake a
little bit of water from the pasta into
my sauce
it goes start twisting the linguine
around I want that Bloody Mary spicing
up the linguine
always hold up the center of the pan
first and place it onto the plate let go
of that nice big lump
by doing this you'll get a mountainous
pile of spaghetti with more body then
generously cover that with your crispy
breadcrumbs absolutely beautiful
[Music]
last but not least I need to cook my
chilled herb buttered lobsters on a
smoking hot griddle
that Butter's gone really nice and firm
so the idea is
snapping that down
and grilling
the smell of that chili and garlic
butter is extraordinary because the
lobsters cooked all you're doing is
grilling that delicious spicy chili
butter you just want that Mark of the
Char quickly on the lobster
turn that over
smell is incredible
[Music]
get that on
[Music]
you can understand why it is proper
special occasion food because that is
mind-blowing
griddled Lobster with chili and garlic
butter served with a boozy Bloody Mary
linguine a sensational special occasion
lunch
on the menu is a succulent rare beef
fillet with salsa available served with
roasted truffle new potatoes the dish is
designed to make your special occasion
one to remember
and to end our Ramsay get together with
a bang I've been listed willing sous
chef Jack to help me make us a blind
chocolate and pistachio semifredo
now I know you love chocolate right
we'll break this up so it melts nice and
evenly
well that goes over memory and you can't
put the chocolate in direct contact with
the gas yeah okay otherwise it will
split crack four eggs in there please
one of course hold one like that on the
side and then your fingers in
and pull out okay because
nice now you're cracking eggs with one
hand hey
nice one I need some muscles okay start
whisking and I'll fold in a bit of sugar
come on let's do 30 seconds each ready
okay come on Jack give it some 13 year
old Welly come on some muscles
10 seconds to go nine eight seven six
five four three two one right here go
your temperature let's go
you see the secret to whisking
vigorously is changing hands every 10
seconds yep now I'm gonna stir the
chocolate I'll stir that here
now the secret behind this is getting it
really nice and thick and that's like
you're stabbing on okay your turn come
on change change again yeah of course
also the chocolate leave that to
slightly cool down a touch
from there cream in
why put in the cream in separately
because I'm gonna get it nice and thick
first if you start whisking that I'm
going to get in the vanilla to maximize
the flavor from our vanilla bean Cut the
pot in half lengthways and scrape out
those wonderfully aromatic seeds
for extra flavor put the pod in as well
but remember to take it out once it's
infused
so we've got three components for melted
chocolate yes sugar yes and the eggs
whipped up and the cream with the
vanilla
next mix in your melted chocolate with
the sugar and egg Sabayon so you've got
a nice rich chocolate ganache smell how
delicious that is
I'm now I'm putting the cream and so you
just
now look at that how gorgeous is that
looking and that my son is a chocolate
semifreddo now a little taste
[Music]
sprinkle them in
now get your bacon train you line that
with clean film so it's easy to put out
once it sets and then you just pour that
in
it's a real treat
so you fold that over okay this this is
like ice cream in any way yeah as it
sets
you slice it it's like this nice
chocolate ice block delicious
then put your semifredo into the freezer
for around three hours to set
right jack get that pan nice and hot
recognize that fillet of beef this is a
Rolls-Royce not beef so we've got to
treat it with some respect okay yeah mop
up all that seasoning here into the pan
and get that really nice and hot hello
teals
kiss my kiss and
what's that holes time what's the name
Rosemary a little bit of garlic and
Thyme in there
cooking with these aromatic herbs and
garlic will add flavor to the beef
because it's a fillet of beef
there's hardly any fat on there so you
sear it quickly ends as well just see it
I'm gonna now put some butter in there
continue frying all those herbs now
baste that with the butter see
this or we're gonna have something
now we're going to serve some beautiful
baked potatoes with truffle and a salsa
verde into the oven eight to ten minutes
that's all
next my super special baked new potatoes
wash and drain small new potatoes and
tip into a baking tray
drizzle with olive oil then season with
a touch of salt and freshly ground black
pepper Place into an oven preheated at
180 degrees Celsius and bake for 35
minutes until crisp on the outside and
soft all the way through
transfer to your serving dish and Grate
over fresh Parmesan cheese
last but not least shave gorgeous earthy
black truffle slivers onto the cheesy
potatoes
bake new potatoes with a lavish twist
indulgent but couldn't be simpler to
make
right salsa birthday anchovies no touch
of anchor of your oil in there okay
after that we've got some capers
garlic in with the anchovies and the
Capers okay A Touch
of salt whining a touch because you've
got yourself that's right Dijon mustard
show everything give that a nice mix and
now this is where it starts to go to a
completely different level some fresh
mint and some fresh parsley I want half
of it in there pureed a touch of olive
oil in there in
the rest of the mint
salt pepper
excited
no taste
I'd love some cookies
what's it taste like fat
you might need to try a tiny bit more
just to check stop don't kiss any boys
now
before the kids polish off all the cells
available I need a distraction and I
think my B fillet will do the job nicely
look at this baby hot holes
up
look at that says and look how juicy and
tender that is take that out and let
that sit on there a little spoon just
while it sits and rests of yourself so
badly as the beef cools down that's
salsa verde marinades that goes the
table very carefully please Tails taking
over the baked potatoes please right
somebody
now
look at that nice
wow and then you just get your chocolate
can you grate it
over
whoa
[Applause]
how delicious is that let's go with Do
not drop that please
Jack
this is my ultimate special occasion
dinner the tenderest rare beef fillet
with Punchy salsa verde
served with extravagant truffle new
potatoes
and a Sublime chocolate and pistachio
semifredo
[Music]